I am transgender and like that's just
like something about me I felt like I'm
proud of and it's like that's not the
first thing I say to someone. But like,
yeah, like, hi, my name is Tyler and track
a viral New York Times article featured
36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people fall in love.
We wanted to see what would happen if
we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
So my name is Skylar.
I don't think I can even remember the
last time I've been in a relationship.
A little more nervous now
that I'm sitting down,
I realize I've never been on a blind date.
I guess I'm just here to find a boyfriend.
That's the short answer here.
Hey, any, you know Skype twinsie twins
on the Louie. I am open minded. Awkward,
nervous for good. What kind of tea
do you lie? I don't really like tea.
I only drink tea and I'm like, and
like, like really bad. So I'm like,
it's he snob so I won't,
maybe I can learn something
by myself.
No tickets alone.
Okay.
It's a hit. It's a hit s guy. You
didn't fuck up too bad. Or like
if a crystal ball could tell
you the truth about yourself,
the future or anything else?
Well,
would you want to know if I knew
something significant? Well,
anything really.
I feel like battle,
like shape the way that I'm kinda
like doing this awkward like thing.
I don't think I would want to know.
What about you?
I guess what I would want to know is
like whether I'm going to find true
happiness in life. One day one of
the crystal ball says no. Like,
are you going gonna just going to be
like, well, I'm not going to be happy.
So I'm out of.
So I don't know.
I guess I would rather know than
just keep living for nothing. Right.
Or is that like a very like, I mean for
me, I didn't look up for me, I don't know.
Maybe that's a little personal
because like as a kid,
like I was so was so depressed,
so depressed and I got to the point where
I honestly felt like life wasn't worth
living. And, um,
and now I'm like happy with who I
am and what my life has to offer.
Even light on the roller coaster up and
downs of it. No, I can relate to the,
I feel like, I'm not going to say who
it is, but there was someone in my life,
I would always just come home like
shout at my mom and I am just like,
I felt like trapped almost and I couldn't
get out of the situation the second I
laughed. That's like when my
happiness like chewy started hopping.
So your own crystal ball,
my own story.
Is there something that you dreamed of
doing for a long time and why haven't you
done it?
I think traveling the world is somebody
I wanted to that I haven't had the
opportunity til I travel
as much as I want to.
I just wish that there weren't
so many boundaries to that.
Like almost like if money and like other
things weren't in bed said like if we
were all just like cave men and we were
just like all walking across the land is
doing it, the whole thing. Oh. So we
can all just travel across the world.
I want to try it well too.
I actually haven't been outside
of the U S and in point, um,
what I dreamed to do,
but I haven't done yet.
It's just like really goal
like 1000000000% with like
my art and just like put
it out there and just be
really unapologetic and like
super confident and all of
that.
I think what's,
what's stopping me is
my confidence honestly.
Like it's like a, it's like a
journey. Like I remember, um,
being like a super like non-competing guy.
I wouldn't share any of my like passions
or talents or anything with anyone.
And now I'm like at this place where
I'm like working on things and putting
things out there.
Just exposing bits and pieces of stuff
myself so I can kind of make it happen.
Yeah.
So it's going to happen,
but like right now I'm like in transit,
I'm in transit.
It hasn't happened yet,
but once my confidence is on point
that I think it'll, it'll be there.
If you were going to become close
friends with your partner, please share.
What would be important for
him or her to know? Dang,
how would I explain this?
Like at the end of the day,
the most important relationship that
they have is the one they have with
themselves. And I'm here to supplement
that. Especially in our generation.
Like everything is so
instant. Everything is so, um,
expectation loaded.
Like you'd do something and you're like,
expect something kind of fun.
Like I would really,
really want them to know that I'm like,
not that,
that's awesome.
How about Chou?
I think what I would want my
partner to know and like what my,
all my friends know about me is
that like I'm transgender and like,
that's just like something
about me that like I'm proud of.
Obviously I would tell my partner
that as like my, all my friends know,
obviously it's like a part of who I am.
Like that's not the first thing I say to
someone. Right. But like, yeah, like, hi,
my name's Tyler and track.
Um,
but like I've been on such a journey
to get to where I am in terms of my
mentality and my mental state, like
who I am. It's an important cause.
The shapes like all of your experience,
the wall that ones say all of you
experienced with him in a lot of different
ways.
Other eyes? Three or four
minutes. I want to take some way.
Okay,
we're ready.
Oh
I wouldn't describe Schuyler
as I would say silly.
She's a little shy and
nervous but very authentic.
He's like pure at heart.
He really does want the best for people.
I can tell she was like garden and she
like kind of like let me in a little bit
which was just enough seeing like how
that Kinda took her to a different place
to me to a different place and
it was like a roller coaster.
Yeah.
Like when you're like trying not to laugh
in class cause your friend's last name
like you said.
Would you be interested in such a date?
I would be to like go as friends.
I don't know if that counts.
Like I don't see myself like with him
but like I would recommend him to my
friends is such a good guy.
I want to like hang out with him one more.
This question is really allow you to
be vulnerable and learn so much about
linkedin person's life and
what their ambitions are.
Our last great.
Absolutely.
I enjoyed my first date with
her. It was, it was really cool.
Hi Guys, I'm Rachel and I'm Dan
and this has been key for two.
This is definitely my favorite series to
film and so we're really happy that you
came to watch and if you want
to be in a future episode,
go ahead and click the link down below.
Like subscribe,
click here to watch more
videos from jubilee media,
me making things and
inspire people to live.
So as always, thank you so much for
watching and we'll see you next time.